So I'm back in England now,
safe and sound as you can clearly see,
which means now I get to tell you about
the second half of my trip to Tanzania.
So still in the region of Tanga,
we went to visit Bombo Hospital
where we got to see some of the really
great work that's being done there
to try and deal
with malnutrition.
Firstly, me and my mum went to a
maternity class where they talked about
the importance of breast feeding
and making sure the mother
has enough nutrients because obviously
that feeds through into the child
and, I mean I'm sure they talked
about a lot of other very interesting stuff,
but the whole thing was in Swahili,
so I didn't quite grasp all of it.
And then we went to
the maternity ward
where we saw these
teeny tiny little babies that
had been born prematurely
and already malnourished
because they just didn't
have enough nutrition
while they will still
inside their mums.
Now my little sister, Bridie,
was born prematurely
and so when she popped out,
the doctors put her
in a little heated glass box called an
incubator to regulate her temperature,
but in Bombo Hospital because
they just don't have the money
to buy decent incubators,
they've had to improvise
and so they've turned an entire room into a
giant incubator just using heated light bulbs
because that's the best that they
could do with what they have.
But after the giant
incubator stage,
provided that the
babies stabilize,
they're introduced
to Kangaroo Care,
which is run by
Sister Josephine and is just,
it's just make do with what
you have at it's absolute finest
and it just warmed the
cockles of my heart.
Here, the tiny little babies are
placed onto their mothers' skin
and because the human
body is incredible,
it recognizes the presence of the
babies and turns the mothers
into living incubators that regulate
the temperature of the little kids.
The program, by the way, is funded
directly by Save the Children,
and it has, appropriately,
saved a lot of children.
It's saved the lives of 6,000 babies just over the
course of the last year. It's freaking incredible.
Next, we got on yet
another tiny little plane
and I got to sit in the
copilot's seat this time,
which made me
incredibly happy,
and we arrived on the island of Zanzibar
to visit some schools in the area.
Now my mum is a primary school teacher,
and a really good one too,
and so this is really where
she came into her element
and got to teach a
couple classes.
She showed them a video
of her class back home
and gave them drawings that her kids had
done for them, writing greetings in Swahili,
and then she encouraged them to think
and talk about food, what they eat.
And just as I was starting to
come to expect from this trip,
not everybody in the class got
to have three meals a day.
In fact, one kid in particular, Adam,
only got to have one meal a day,
which was just some
rice and that's it,
and he particularly touched my mum's
heart as well when he said
that he wanted to become
a teacher like her.
It's the kind of example,
really, of an instance
where you just want to
take little Adam home
and give him all of the
food that he wants
because it's these kind
of personal stories
that really do hit home, especially
when you see them in person,
but it's important to remember that Adam
is an example of a much bigger problem,
and that is what the
IF campaign is about.
I hope that you can see that this issue is one
that has become very important to me,
and so if you would like to help out, the most
important thing we can do, honestly,
is just make it clear to the people
who have the power to change this
that this is something
that we care about.
I'll put a link down here to a
petition that you can sign,
but just as good is just
talking about this publicly,
here on YouTube or on any
of the other websites.
Just whatever way
you can think of.
Thank you. I really hope you
can get involved in this.
I also want to say thank you to
Rosie and Daldy at Save the Children
for making this
trip happen
and to Frank, as well,
for letting me be your friend.
Very nice of you.
That's all.
Good bye!
FRANK: Join Charlie to
ending hunger. Thank you.
CHARLIE VOICE: That's perfect.
Thanks, Frank.
LAUGHTER
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
UKULELE PLAYING
♪This is my face♪
♪On my head♪
♪On my shoulders♪
♪With eyes♪
♪And a mouth♪
♪And a nose♪